Chances are pretty good that you've already
seen Avengers: Endgame and don't need this
spoiler warning — but, as you no doubt know,
Tony Stark doesn't make it out of Endgame
alive.
Since so much of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
has been built around Stark and his armor-clad
alter ego, his absence leaves a pretty big
vacuum.
But will it stay that way forever?
Maybe...maybe not.
Here's how Iron Man just might return to the
MCU, in one form or another.
One of the best things about having a hero
whose powers come from a suit of armor is
that almost anyone can wear it, assuming they're
the kind of person who doesn't mind flying
around with rocket-boots and shooting bad
guys with repulsor rays.
If that's the case, then there's no better
candidate for the new Iron Man than Colonel
Jim Rhodes, who already has plenty of experience
in the suit.
"I'm gonna have to hang onto your suit for
a minute, OK?"
"Not OK.
Not OK with that."
"Wasn't a question."
That's not what makes Rhodey the obvious choice,
though.
In comics, he's been better known as War Machine
for decades, but Rhodey's first major story
came when he took over the identity of Iron
Man while Tony was struggling with alcoholism.
His tenure as the Armored Avenger lasted for
four years, and even saw him as the version
of Iron Man who went off to fight in the Secret
Wars event.
Rhodey has the added bonus of being a known
quantity among MCU fans.
Don Cheadle might've replaced Terrence Howard
with the second movie in the Iron Man franchise,
but the character has been around since the
first Iron Man film.
Then again, that might be a detriment.
Cheadle's the same age as Downey, and while
that obviously didn't keep him from some epic
superhero action in Endgame, filmmakers might
be looking for someone younger going forward.
Endgame paid off plenty of plot points and
lived up to its promise of being the end of
an era, but the MCU shows no sign of slowing
down anytime soon.
So it makes sense that Endgame would also
lay down a little foreshadowing of its own.
If that's the case, then there might be a
good reason why Morgan Stark, Tony's five
year-old daughter, is introduced to us wearing
one of Tony's helmets and a toy Repulsor,
and why a huge chunk of the movie is devoted
to Tony reconciling with his own father.
From helping found S.H.I.E.L.D. to helping
found the Avengers and Pepper showing up as
Rescue, superheroism is a family business
for the Starks.
There's no reason why Morgan couldn't eventually
carry on that legacy.
The obvious problem there is that Morgan Stark
is five years old.
It's also completely uncharted territory.
Unlike Rhodey, who's a well-known quantity
as Iron Man, Tony Stark has never had a kid
in the comics.
There is an existing Morgan Stark on the page,
but he's Tony's nefarious cousin who constantly
attempts to take over his business.
If the MCU wants to get really weird, there's
one very unlikely character who could take
up the armor as the all-new Iron Man: Peter
Parker.
Spider-Man is, after all, one of Marvel's
most popular characters.
And with Into the Spider-Verse's critical
acclaim, he's one of the only superheroes
who can carry two simultaneous film franchises
that, for now at least, have nothing to do
with each other.
In fact, the latest trailer for Spider-Man:
Far From Home heavily implies that Peter is
actually thinking along these lines:
"The world needs the next Iron Man!"
So yeah, it could definitely happen — but
it's almost certain that it won't.
Blending his role with Iron Man's wouldn't
really do either one of those brands any favors,
and would probably dilute the elements that
make each of them work on their own.
Still, there's a level where it would actually
make sense.
From the moment he stepped onto the screen
in Captain America: Civil War, Tony has mentored
Peter, looking to avoid making the same mistakes
his father made when it came to dealing with
a teenage super-genius.
"All right.
I've run out of patience.
Underoos!"
There's an almost familial connection there,
which we see in Endgame when the only people
who really get to mourn for Tony on the battlefield
are Peter Parker and Pepper Potts.
Tony has even provided Spider-Man with his
equipment, giving him the high-tech version
of his familiar suit that he wears in Homecoming,
and the "Iron Spider" armor that we see him
wearing in Infinity War and Endgame.
It's a relationship that they've never really
had in the comics, and if he was any other
character, Peter would be the obvious choice
to take over.
As it stands, we're definitely getting a further
examination of that mentoring relationship,
but it's far more likely to end with Spider-Man
deciding to strike out on his own.
If the MCU really wants to move forward and
put a younger character into the armor, they
don't need to go for something as wild as
Peter Parker: Iron Man.
The comics have served up a ready-made replacement
in the form of Riri Williams, better known
as Ironheart.
Introduced in 2016, Riri is a teenage genius
from Chicago who reverse-engineered Stark
technology and built her own suit of Iron
Man armor.
Since Tony Stark was dead at the time and,
as is often the case in comics, he got better
she wound up fighting crime, assisted by an
AI version of Tony.
Eventually, after a meeting with Pepper, she
wound up creating her own suit from scratch
and taking the identity of Ironheart.
As far as replacements go, she'd definitely
be an interesting one.
But the fact that she has an established separate
superheroic identity that's already appeared
in cartoons would seem to make that unlikely.
Still, there's one really cool connection
to the roots of the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Back in 2008, Tony Stark built his first suit
of Iron Man armor in a cave.
Riri built hers in the garage.
Echoing those roots in a different form would
be a nice way to go forward.
Maybe Marvel doesn't actually want to replace
Tony Stark as Iron Man.
Maybe they want to bring him back, but also
make sure that they don't undermine the sacrifice
he made to defeat Thanos.
If so, there's one way that they can have
their armor-plated cake and eat it, too: they
could give us the film version of Teen Tony.
The comics killed off Tony Stark in 1996 after
revealing he was secretly a villain and attempted
to attract new readers by replacing him with
a teenaged version of Tony from another dimension.
Like the original Tony, he had to wear the
armor to keep his heart beating, but did so
as a cool '90s youth who didn't have a mustache.
He also didn't have much success in the whole
"get people to read this comic" thing, and
was killed off via heroic sacrifice ten months
later, quickly becoming one of those weird
comics things that we just don't talk about
much.
Still, it's been 22 years, and that's enough
time to give this idea another shot by casting
a young CW star as the all-new Tony Stark.
We even have more than a few hints that the
MCU might be introducing a full-on multiverse
as of Spider-Man: Far from Home, giving him
or any other alternate Tony the perfect opportunity
to jump into the MCU.
"You're saying there's a multiverse?"
Is teen Tony going to happen?
Probably not, but, that's exactly what we
would've said if you told us ten years ago
that Rocket Raccoon, Crossbones, and M'Baku
were going to be in the same
movie, and that it was going to be one of
the biggest blockbusters of all time.
Time makes fools of us all.
There's another alternate version of Iron
Man who seems like he's begging for a comeback:
Arno Stark, the Iron Man of 2020.
He was introduced in 1984, when 2020 still
seemed like the far-off future.
The basic idea is that he was a younger cousin
of Tony Stark's who used a scary-looking version
of the Iron Man suit to act as a mercenary.
Thanks to the magic of time travel, Iron Man
2020 wound up fighting Spider-Man in 1986
and Iron Man in 1990 in what was a surprisingly
uneventful career as a supervillain.
With 2020 on the horizon, it might not surprise
you to learn that Marvel has been laying the
seeds for Arno to make a return in the comic
books.
Most recently, it's turned out that Tony was
actually adopted, and that Howard and Maria
Stark's first child, Arno, had been the subject
of genetic experimentation by an alien robot,
which caused them to adopt Tony.
It's… complicated.
Arno eventually made his return as a relatively
heroic character who teamed up with Tony,
and is currently floating around the Marvel
Universe, presumably waiting to live up to
his name.
Obviously, that's some complicated stuff even
by Marvel standards.
But hey: the opportunity to use Iron Man 2020
in 2020 only comes around once.
If Tony Stark himself is going to make a comeback,
then there's an easy way to pull it off without
cheapening his death in Endgame: Just have
Tony return as an artificial intelligence.
This has been done before in the comics, most
recently with the aforementioned A.I.
Tony that helped Riri Williams build her armor
and served as her on-board computer.
Of course, in the comics, living artificial
intelligence characters are a dime a dozen,
but the MCU isn't far off itself.
Friday and Karen, the onboard A.I. for Spider-Man's
Stark-designed suit, both have distinct personalities,
and J.A.R.V.I.S., the Iron Man suit's original
A.I., was even able to evolve into a full-on
superhero in Age of Ultron, when it became
the Vision.
This all depends on how truly done with the
role Robert Downey Jr. is.
But all things considered, it seems like a
pretty likely way to get Tony back into the
mix.
A holographic Tony serving as the onboard
A.I.for a character like Riri or Morgan or
Rhodey would be a nice way to bridge the gap
to a new Iron Man.
Or he could even control an empty suit of
armor himself.
If Iron Man is going to come back, then there's
nothing that says he has to be a good guy.
A new Iron Man could use Tony's name and technology
for sinister ends.
That's actually the premise of one of the
most well-known and beloved Iron Man stories,
"Armor Wars."
The premise is that Tony finds out that his
tech has been used by armored villains like
the Titanium Man, the Crimson Dynamo, and
even Stilt-Man, and he goes all-out to destroy
their armor so that his creations can't be
used for evil.
The MCU obviously lacks the sheer number of
armored enemies that the comics have built
up over the past 60 years, but between Obadiah
Stane's recreation of the armor in Iron Man,
Justin Hammer's mass-produced knockoffs in
Iron Man 2, and all of those pieces of the
armor that were destroyed in Iron Man 3, there's
enough of it out there that it's not implausible
that someone could build their own, especially
if they had an uninterrupted five-year span
to work on it.
The idea of Pepper and Rhodey teaming up to
save Tony's legacy is compelling, and a villain
co-opting Tony's signature line...
"I am Iron Man."
...is almost so easy that it's tough to imagine
not doing it.
Plus, dealing with the idea of the legacy
these heroes leave, blurring the definitive
lines between heroes and villains that we've
seen in Endgame, and examining the Iron Man
suit as a weapon whose morality is determined
entirely by its user...all that would be an
interesting way to move forward in a world
without Tony Stark.
One of Marvel's most popular characters in
recent years has been Squirrel Girl.
No, really.
She's the star of a long-running and award-winning
comic, and she's set to appear as the lead
in an upcoming New Warriors TV series.
While Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D. and the Netflix
Marvel shows are technically set in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe, TV and movie projects
have always been pretty separate.
If, however, the MCU wants to tie things together,
there's one way they could generate some intense
brand synergy and recreate an iconic moment
from the comics.
Just have the new Iron Man be based on the
scene where an evil duplicate of Squirrel
Girl kidnaps Tony Stark and convinces her
rodent pals to crawl into his armor and scurry
around trying to operate it, with predictably
disastrous results.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.